I mean how many outfits have you done
today I've been going since four in the
morning and back to back so I don't even
know how many office changes it's
probably been about 10 so far if you had
time for little Phoenix today he's in La
he's just so little I didn't want to
have him travel this far we go to London
tomorrow for the rest of the press tour
I can't wait to get home to him I can
only imagine Pearson congratulations on
that front and I got to tell you this
book is quite the read what is the
biggest lesson you've learned that's
been revealed to you in writing this
Memoir this has just been the most
therapeutic experience of my life just
putting it all out there and
just put so many emotions and just so
many experiences that I endured and
tried to forget but writing them all out
and putting it out there has just been
this made me feel just really incredible
yeah and sometimes there's healing and
not sweeping things under the rug right
I mean you even write your story has
more power than you can imagine and I
hope you feel empowered after riding
this I feel incredibly empowered and
to read everything that I've went
through and how resilient and brave that
I am you strong but I mean in finding
that power and writing about your
experiences so much trauma that you have
experienced in your adolescent life what
is the scariest part that you're
thinking oh my gosh I'm kind of afraid
to put that out there the world is
finally going to be able to reveal the
world is going to be revealed to my
inner secret ever since my documentary
this is Paris this is the first time
that I was vulnerable and spoke about so
many things I went through and just in
the past two and a half years just how
much impact it's made on others and
helping change laws and just really
being the hero that I always needed when
I was a little girl so I just couldn't
be prouder
this is like the perfect companion to
this is Paris you know you're diving
deeper into some of the topics that you
discussed in that documentary but now
that you are an open book in this book
you were in the documentary as well but
how how is it different deciding what
you share and what you don't share
especially now that you are a mama to a
son Phoenix I've lived such a full and
exciting life so the book has it all
everything that I've went through in
life but also the really great times and
I know that Phoenix would be just proud
of his mom and how strong she is and
also just letting others know that
they're not alone and feeling
comfortable to tell their story I think
there's just so much power and coming
forward with your truth
yeah in part did you write this for
Phoenix or any future children someday
so they could hear mommy's Tales
just feel that the media has really
controlled my narrative for over two
decades and nobody knew the true story
so I just felt it was time to really say
what what's true today was just
announced that Lindsay Lohan is
expecting her first child with her
husband how excited are you for Lindsay
and what kind of first-time Mama advice
would you like to give her I'm so
excited for her I know that she's always
wanted to be a mom and she seems like
she's in such an amazing place with her
new man so I'm just so happy for her any
tips for the first time Mama
so just take in all the special moments
because
they grow up so fast he's only two
months old every day he's growing more
and more so it's just good just to soak
in every moment what are your favorite
moments of Phoenix favorite moments are
at night when he's just laying on my
chest and he's looking into my eyes and
my heart just melts and I just feel just
just this is just the most magical time
of my life you got your two loves now
Carter and my two boys what did your
mama Kathy think you didn't tell her
about the birth of your son until a week
after he was born what was her reaction
she was very surprised and so just happy
and excited but for me I just was
something that I wanted to keep private
and I feel like my life has been so
public and I don't know if when you're a
mom you're so excited to tell everybody
the news so
I knew I had to keep it a secret how
long did you keep it a secret
until he was a week old so it was a week
old for your mom and for the rest of us
for everyone forever oh my gosh you're
sweet mama
much of your motherhood Journey your son
will we see in season two of Paris in
love because clearly girl the cameras
are here right now we're here they've
been filming for several months now so
they've captured everything so it'll be
out on peacock soon okay all right and
are you hoping to maybe put pen to paper
in regards to what you've been taught
about motherhood in the past couple of
months in another book form or obviously
in season two of Harrison love but in
another book Maybe that's hot
[Music]
foreign